[Music]
my name is George Talbott I'm a staff
self wear engineer at Google and I'm
responsible for a chunk of our planet
scale of the planet scaled monitoring
your infrastructure I'll tell you a
little bit about what that is give you a
little bit of background so monitoring
at Google I should say monitoring Google
is a global problem we have data centers
and points of presence all over the
world that they're full of computers
that we used to run our services so
besides that global span we have a huge
volume we monitor billions of things
every job running on every computer at
Google Network hardware operating
systems various infrastructure services
and it's everything from bigger to
smaller services so it's hundreds of
billions of values of being measured at
any one time and we ingest about two and
a half terabytes per second we have a
pretty strong culture of people
monitoring their systems you don't run
something in production if you don't
know how it works and you aren't
measuring how well it's working right
now every team is responsible for
setting up their monitoring and learning
for their services and this is
constantly changing as new services
happen new ways to monitor things happen
so we have to evolve with it so one of
the parts of the talk later that I enjoy
a lot is some of the lessons we've
learned in scaling a system like this
from something that's smaller it is
something that covers all of Google so
I'll talk to you a little bit about the
architecture and data model of our
system and I'll try to interject here's
where the streaming happens so we have
data centers all over the globe we need
to monitor things all over the globe
where do we start well we start with
local monitoring we break the world into
zones in a zone is like a strongly
connected network region think of like a
building full of computers and data
centers and stuff like that so we
monitor
and stored locally within a zone so we
store data near where it's collected we
manage we managed alert and query
globally and monitoring in the zone is
part of that larger system and but we
can operate autonomously like if a data
center is disconnected from the rest of
the world because you know somebody
dragged a backhoe across a fiber-optic
cable or something and this is
monitoring as a service people don't
stand up their own monitoring jobs and
production we run it for you
so let's look inside one of these zones
so monarch zone ingestion queries
retention evaluation notification etc so
let's start with ingestion ingestion
starts with some sort of monitored
entity that that you care about
maybe it's your jobs running on our
cluster maybe you're a network person
you care about the hardware etc
everything is instrumented we call our
library Stream Z and it defines classes
which define metrics which is the unit
of information that we monitor and as
the ability to contact our system and
send data about that entity to monarch
so we know about it so metrics are the
unive a unit of information we monitor
I'll tell you a little bit bit about
what that is so a metric is our basic
measurement of some aspect of that
monitored target so it has a static
descriptor you know a name of value type
classification fields so here's an
example this is response latency x' for
HTTP classified by pat the string path
and the response code and the value is a
distribution which is a histogram plus
population plus statistics so that you
can compute percentiles and it's
constructed in such a way that you can
add these things together over many
serve servers so you could say well what
is my 95th percentile HTTP response
latency over these thousand machines
that are serving my website so each
entity has labels that classify the that
entity and we could call that a target
so there's a mechanism to fit the labels
that the these jobs export that identify
themselves into a fixed schema we call a
target schema so here's an example of a
job running on our Borg task scheduling
system where you sort of the previous
internal predecessor of kubernetes Borg
identifies by user job name cell which
is essentially data center and task
number so if you've started up a
thousand tasks for a particular job
that's the number of the individual
tasks this is a very common target
scheme at Google but you can have other
ones and it gives us an ordered space of
space of names for targets and when I
say orders it's like let's think
lexicographical ordering of the targets
where we concatenate the fields together
so ingestion so this is here is where
some of the streaming is so the the
targets use this library to write to us
and that comes to an ingestion router
and then ingestion router identify it
takes little name value pairs from the
the job that identified the entity and
turn it into those target schema I took
the talked about a minute ago and then
we can use that as a key to figure out
where the data should land in our
backends also as data is streaming in to
us we have situations where there's some
users that have so much data that you
can't actually store it all so we can do
some pre aggregation as the data comes
in before it gets stored so where's the
these ingestion routers put the data
that they get they put them in what we
call the leaf and this is the central
job tourism zone monitoring you know
leaves are the things that we're running
all over the world that record our data
into an in-memory database and there's
sort of the lowest level in our
hierarchy so the targets are apportioned
to the leaves by lexicographical range
and the ingestion routers track these
ranges to get the data in here leaves
send their leaves right their data to
recovery logs which I'll talk a little
bit a little bit more later which which
are actually the
ground truth of what's in this
monitoring system so the the targets and
individual metric bout values the leaf
retains streams of these values so a
stream looks like this a stream has an
identifier and history so the identifier
is essentially a kid the concatenated
labels from the target that identify
what the thing you're monitoring and the
metric which is the measurement and then
the history is time stamp value time
stamp value from youngest to oldest and
it comes from the sequence of values for
that target and that measurement sent to
the leaf so from a query perspective
these streams are gathered together into
tables for each target schema and metric
pair this gives a specific structure we
have columns from the targets columns
from the metric fields and then a column
for the actual time series data and it
looks like a relational table and it's
this is physically distributed across
all those zones and leaves and
everywhere but logically from the point
of view of some Aquarion our system they
just see this table so I'll talk a
little bit about retention so I was
talking about recovery logs and whatnot
before so these leaves are writing to
recovery logs which are used to like if
a leaf crashes it has to be able to read
its state and and run again
there's also because we're divvying up
our range lexa graphically
lexicographically and not by like a hash
or something like that we have to have
constant load balancing because you
might have one part of the key range get
hot or whatever and that's this assign
our task and that uses the recovery logs
to move ranges around in a seamless
manner because you can say okay you're
recording this measurement you start
recording it to read the history
histories read okay you stop recording
it now we've moved the load from one
thing to another
it also gives a ton a path to a our
historical repository
we can save data in a long longer period
of time which is a little bit outside
the scope of this talk so queries happen
within a local zone queries come into a
job called called a zone mixer we'll
talk in a little bit more detail about
queries a little later so the zone mixer
will select leaves based on where it
thinks the data is it sends the queries
to them the leaves will combine data
from their in-memory database and
whatever might be in that historical
repository that's relevant and they do
their part they send the data back to
the mixer the mixer does its part and it
sends the result back to the originator
and this is done in a streaming fashion
as well you know you can do queries that
you can that are much larger than any
node can fit in memory and the data
streams through with some clever
buffering at each node pardon me so
here's the part where we wake people up
in the night so we have an evaluator
that's running standing queries which
serve sort of like materialized views
that that people set up to like let's
say you're doing an aggregation and a
percentile to say well if my latency
goes over you know 250 milliseconds make
my pager go off because something's
broken that's what this evaluator job
does and it sends queries to the zone
rates the data back into the zone and
then can look at alerting thresholds and
decide oh well time to wake them up so
that's a monarch zone it's a
self-contained monitoring system in a
zone but we have a worldwide monitoring
problem well how does that work so the
zones are integrated into a single
system by global monarch which is
logically centralized you know it's the
place a user interacts with our system
but it is itself physically distributed
this provides a global view of what's
going on in zones and has the machinery
for each user to configure what monarchs
going to do for that user so first
configuration configuration resides in a
distributed spanner database like if you
read about our cloud spanner product the
same thing with lots of read replication
the configuration is whatever the user
wants to collect how long do they want
to retain it for what are their metrics
whether their target scheme is what
queries are they doing to drive their
alerts and their and their dashboards
and the actual contents of dashboards
etc for queries route mixers have the
same relation to zones that the zone
mixers have to leaves so query well your
query will come in to the root mixer and
that will say well I think that data is
in these Geographic zones fan the query
out to those zones then it goes through
the zone process comes back and it comes
back to you and this is logically
centralized but it's physically
distributed so we're running route
mixers all over the world and we can do
evaluation with the global level as well
if for example you want to say well did
my the global QPS for my service go way
down wake me up so scaling horizontally
is the key point for our system we have
this unified global system where we
collect retain query it's distributed
and robust but as we get bigger we don't
make one thing bigger we make a new
zones so let's look at queries for a
minute so that we have this is we have
actually multiple query notations this
is a Python based query notation and
it's this is a basic example select the
fetch select streams which with which we
want to operate upon so here we're
looking at Gmail's
successful response response latency for
successful requests and here's more
streaming we is a pipe based notation so
you can mentally think of the data
streams out of the fetch streams through
a window operation that aligns the data
in time right so this is this is saying
well show me the Delta over five minutes
you know how much you know how much did
my my response latency change over five
minutes and then group i stream that
into group i which is doing aggregation
stream that into a percentile which
takes the aggregated distribution
aggregate
histogram it figures out where 95th
percentile is this is a basic example
the query notation can do lot a lot more
joins top streams map stream ID unions
general expressions there's a lot of
aggregation functions as well so queries
proceed from the global to local backed
up global and in each step mixers decide
what part of the query they will execute
in what parts they delegate the thing
that's kind of interesting about our
system is that the whole query comes
into the route the route figures out
where it's gonna fan it out to but it
doesn't send the whole query down it
sends what part of the query it thinks
is relevant to that zone will get sent
to it and then the zone mixers do the
same thing where they're kind of cutting
down the query to say here's what goes
to individual leaves and where these
things go geographically is determined
by physical locations in the data and
there's target schema will say oh well
this is cell a B and that's in zone I
don't know I - I aligned or something
right so the query proceeds at this own
level aggregation and we figure out from
that query before that because we were
aggregating by cell it has to happen at
the zone level so we'll compute the
aggregation and the percentile there and
that gets sent down to the leaves and
the leaves will do the fetch will do
some the window some of the aggregation
work return intermediate results and
then the results propagate back up and
they're finalized that the zone level
and pass to the global level the other
thing that's interesting here in the
streaming sense is as things are passed
between these these levels you know this
is a big distributed computation with
data flowing through it so the key to
getting this working right is to have
really good in memory quota management
at each node so that so that like you
can have one query that
denial-of-service is everybody so we
have a global monitoring system how do
we use it tell you that a little bit so
this is one of our internal front ends
called panopticon it's used to can buy
engineers to configure our system and
serve
oh yeah I know thank you from my
experience that's do well in general we
tend to store as much of the raw data as
we can at those leaf nodes during the
query you're aggregating together based
on what your query wants you know based
on does that make sense
oh you're oh you're talking about like
the distribute the histogram stuff
specifically it's bucketed histograms
the user picks the resolution so you
know and then what yeah and then the
percentile will be an interpolation so
does that make sense and we're working
on more sophisticated ways of
automatically picking those buckets yes
yes sure thing
so going back to this I'll just tell you
a little bit about one of the front ends
users can configure what they what
targets they want to retain data for for
how long for in memory for on disk
whether there's down sampling that sort
of thing we have a GUI that walks you
through building queries which in some
ways I prefer to writing actual query
notation because you see all the
different parameters you can define
alerts so you can be woken up at night
and you could set up consoles with
collections of graphs common controls
navigation that sort of thing and I'll
talk a little bit about it as a platform
you know we don't want to
just say oh here's monarch everybody you
figure it out right so we try to make it
a little easier for our users and
simplify the learning curve so we have a
custom console service that people can
build their own consoles we have
configuration libraries that encode our
best practices so you don't have to
figure out oh how do I build a job
flapping alert how do I build alert that
that that respects dreams when parts of
the infrastructure or powered down for
maintenance or something like that we
have automatic and Kross company
monitoring so you defer they Bates basic
things like job flapping or our PC
latency or counts or error counts you
don't actually have to setup everything
anything we actually monitor that all
that for you across the whole company
and it helps you set up SLA S&S loz and
how and we have automated monitoring for
rollouts which happen all the time we're
also the backend for the cloud product
and we monitor all the cloud customers
and services that those customers use
and there was a lot of and development
that went into this like encryption at
rest and we carefully controlled and
audited access to the data because you
know customer data and we have slightly
different ways of naming things and data
model with some powerful query
extensions that help define groups that
can change at runtime and stuff like
that so that's this is my favorite part
is some of the lessons that I learned
when we're building the system I've been
on this project for a while and building
systems at this that grow to the scale
can be kind of interesting so I've
learned basically three basic lessons
building this system first good hygiene
like concurrency and stuff
scaling horizontally is the only way
tracked achill way to scale a system
like this and it's really challenging
and then for large users with high
cardinality you often have to reduce
their dimensions as the data comes in
they kind of you often can't
afford to store all their raw data like
if you think of like I know every user
on every bytes for every user on every
disk at Google this is an insanely large
number so let me talk about some of
these lessons learned so the first
lessons learned lesson learned is good
hygiene so this is really about how you
develop your individual components for
us it's properly concurrent data
structures so we had a situation where a
couple years ago each of these backends
and there's those leaf backends to give
me an idea of scale the part of our
system that monitors Google not Cloud I
can't really give you numbers for cloud
the part of the system the monitors
Google there's a hundred twenty thousand
of those leaf processes right and a
couple years ago each of those processes
was getting about 200 queries per second
you know because we're Fanning queries
out to different things based on the
data we jump from two hundred to a
thousand to two thousand to five
thousand queries per second in the space
of six months and boy did we find out
that we had some concurrency bottlenecks
to fix you know we had locks protecting
important data structures and that sort
of thing so that was interesting so you
have to care about concurrency and
individual backends could as it affects
the system properties of as a whole you
know what don't have long tails you
don't want to let components languish
too long you can have a component that
seems like it's working fine working
fine working fine and then the system
goes to hell because you weren't paying
attention that that thing was getting
close to a scale a critical scaling
limit that happened like not this summer
but last summer with one of our that
assignor thing and it we had an outage
where it took twelve hours and a couple
zones for that assignor to come back
which made us reassess and redesign it
and we in the one of the related latest
outages were that made the news when
networking came back we had because of
our redesign we came back within 20
minutes which was good
we have to deprecate old api's because
they get in the way of scaling we moved
from pole to push collection and saved
you know a fiscal equivalent of a dozen
engineers worth of RAM does an engineer
salaries worth of RAM and removed and
outage prone components so that was
interesting that took years because it
touched every binary at Google and then
outliers any of these large systems that
care about performance for users like
how many nines they can deliver the
users you have to look at outliers like
we had a recent case where there were
back at we we test in our test cell
crashing all the back ends and bringing
on the back because sometimes a user can
send a query of death and what happens
when they come back and we notice they
were like out of several thousand of
these leaf processes that were like
maybe a dozen who had elevated CPU for a
while and we've looked at that and we
figured out what that was and fixed it
and it turned out that we gained another
nine in reliability of certain things
like that pre aggregation
oddly enough so you have to care about
that or you won't be reliable so this is
a big lesson for us scaling horizontally
it's really hard but it's the only way
to scale a system like this so for us
it's increasing the number of leaves in
the number of zones and we have to watch
for centralized services to become
bottlenecks like that assignor thing we
have to look worried about non-constant
per back-end cost co as the system grows
what you want to do is you want to start
up new backends and every data structure
inside each back-end should be about the
same size you should just have more of
them that's not always easy to guarantee
especially for configuration it can be
hard to figure out what configuration
like like what the what the the thing
that tells the each of these things what
data is to retain has to be pared down
to meant match the data yeah I got that
tripping up for a second and query costs
should fan out in a constant manner as
well and we have a bloom filter indexing
service that helps us do that
finally reducing dimensions early can be
important for large users we aggregate
data as it arrives for large users and
it's interesting because configuration
and data multiplexing during that
reduction is more expensive than the
aggregation itself like figuring out
what data and where it should go is more
important and we can also we also want
to be able to see through aggregations
and that's as a user thing and to give
you an idea of scale this out of that
two and a half terabytes per second
about 1.8 terabytes of that is actually
aggregated on the fly as it comes in so
this is part of that aggregation so
here's here's aggregating over several
thousand test jobs and we can see the
latency started to blow out and we're
showing this as a heat map so we can
propagate traces through if people have
used distributed tracing or do some
sampling and figure out when we
aggregate things well what were the what
were the labels before when we were
aggregating so we've clicked on one part
of that latency latency hump there and
it's highlighted that most of that's
from one server so when you're when
we're doing that pre aggregation we have
to keep track of things so that we can
show the user that oh add of those
thousands of things that we sum together
to get this graph here's the one thing
that was causing you a problem so anywho
that's the lessons we learned scaling
our system and this is a sampling that
kind of I enjoy and that's about it
thank you I think I was some time for
questions
who named your app panopticon that's a
hell of a reference yeah you know it's
from an earlier more innocent time
gotcha
as far as I'm aware this is the
successor to Boardman yes despite
prometheus can you talk more about the
trade offs or why you create an entirely
new system for monitoring yes so the a
few reasons one of them is that we
wanted more uniformity in how we monitor
our systems at Google you know they're
they're large SRA teams that really know
what what they're doing right and we
want their knowledge to be sort of
leveraged across everybody else's so
that's the first thing and that's
probably the most important the second
one is its costly an error prone to have
every team standing up their own
monitoring jobs and costly meeting it's
a lot of work for the SRT teams and it's
a lot of it's more machine resources
than monarchist we can we can amortize
over economies of scale when we do that
so that was a big thing we have better
data model than that did like those
histograms our first class data type in
our system so let me go back here so you
see this people are so used to looking
at percentile lines that get spit out by
things but it's actually not the right
model because like in this case there
was one job that created that latency
hump right you can go say oh it's that
one job kill it and you know maybe the
load will get redistributed and you'll
bring up another one but if all the but
if the whole histogram moved up that's
telling you a different thing about your
system minimum and might be that one of
your dependencies got a lot worse and
all your jobs are doing worse right so
having things like like the exemplars
that drive this picking out your one job
that was bad we're seeing the heat maps
directly and being able to compute over
that has been crucial to sort of
leveling up how people view their
systems and
especially with these like layered
systems where you might have the disks
than a disc server than a distributed
file system and then a distributed
database and all that each one has their
own little latency hump rate and
sometimes when you look at these graphs
you can see oh here's the hump where
there's a ram cache in the drive and
here's the hump where there's a ram
cache in the disk server etc etc so you
can kind of see the different ways that
these things assemble up so that was the
other thing is that we wanted to sort of
upgrade people's notions of what they
could do with monitoring and frankly
Boardman didn't have the data model with
you know the column in their data model
and that made a real big difference too
sorry if that was long but that's you
know thank you uh to follow up on that
actually you mentions to all of these
layers did you two question there did
you mean that you're monitoring espada
job performance an actual let's say
behavior of disk or and the second part
is like if part of the job happens in
like a storage layer and part of it
happens in like a lab Larry yeah you
basically enforce like I'm just gonna
keep how do you correlate it to a single
how do you enforce correlating that all
to a single flaw well the thing that I
found interesting it's funny I was the
one that added the heat map display to
our tool right and the thing that we
found interesting when we look directly
at the data you could look at just the
latency some at the top level of the
system and often see the Bandit bands in
it that just naturally fell out of the
data and then we're like well what's
that then you get an engineer who knows
the storage stack and he'll say well
that latency hump is from this part of
the system that one's from that part of
the system you know what I mean it's
like you you have sort of emergent
properties that come out of me data so
that was that was actually fascinating
to me who especially when I started
doing this I wasn't his experience with
these large distributed
systems say it was an in-memory database
how much data do you hold or leave for
I'm trying to figure out what I can
actually tell you but it's many
petabytes of RAM to the holding that
data and that's that's the in memory of
you see when we immediate monitoring is
in memory because a monitoring system
like this is low dependency and we don't
depend on a lot of other services
because we have to operate when
literally things are on fire right so
when like when that evaluators doing
queries for alerts that's only hitting
the in-memory data because we don't want
to rely on that that distributed file
system exists right now or that the
database on top of that exists right now
there might be things that don't exist
right now because you know things have
gone crazy but we still want to get that
alert out to that person you know and
even when the data center is
disconnected we want to get that alert
out so there's things like cellular
modems and our data centers and stuff to
get those alerts out just in case
hey so given the way you're describing
the scale of this and can you use
monarch to monitor itself we do we run a
separate copy of monarch to monitor
monarch you know you gonna have to suite
um so something that occurred to me
right is like I'm watching hear talk and
it looks like you start with like proper
metrics right like a number and then you
like I could get them early in often
which you know okay scaling right but
like you know you know I've also been
listening in people talking about like
observability and they're talking about
like these like big like rich like
events that like get it right and and so
I guess like what I'm wondering is like
okay let's say use you're looking at
this like flame graph and you see
something and you want to like drill
down somehow like your system wouldn't
be able to support
like the proper like or proper sort but
like it wouldn't support like honeycomb
style like observability is so like deal
like a separate system for that do
you're just like like well in some ways
it kind of does actually because we we
were monitoring logging and tracing are
pretty closely welded together so like
in a graph like this you see see this
that's a trace and if I click on that
trace the the monitoring gives
contextualization to the trace right so
here's a trace where things were
probably okay things were probably okay
here things were okay here things were
not okay here let me click on that and
drill down to what I care about
it will drill you down to the trace it
will drill you down to because we've
retained labels through our aggregations
for this it will tell and we have the
precise time instant because we took an
example here we can drill you down to
the right coordinate in the logs to so
you do get you do get sort of that log
and observability that a trace will give
you through a system without having to
look at all the graphs of everything
it's not as nice as honey what honey
comes doing with their you eyes and
everything don't get me wrong but we
[Music]